[Music]
hello everyone welcome back for another
tip 2019 interview excited to talk about
this one with the team behind the giant
hello how are you doing are you serving
just barely yes grape and vice I feel
like I don't know why this has become my
thing in these interviews but to reward
yourself for a successful evening
because you're gonna have a wonderful
premiere tonight go after to sweet Jesus
and get yourself some ice cream what
sweet Jesus the light box and it's
phenomenal
okay scream dipped in all these
elaborate toppings and oh I love ice
cream I talk about all the time it's the
quickest path from ice cream to the
giant first thing I wanted to ask you
about was specifically working with
camera ready pictures because I was
reading a little about them and one of
their mission statements was it's a
company's vision of boundary-pushing
cinema which I really respect because
it's not easy to get that kind of stuff
off the ground so what's it like
collaborating with them and specifically
getting the go-ahead the green light to
make the Giants look like you asked this
it was their first movie it was my first
movie Denis Mazal the producer of the
film is a wonderful man and I can't say
enough nice things about him we we had a
couple like introductory meetings and
then he sent the script to his wife and
she had a dream about it and that's how
we got the green light the boobies about
there's dreams throughout the film and
there it was kismet
it really was he comes from like sort of
an art benefactor sort of background so
he is someone who believes that the work
is the work and it's it is the product
of the author and I could not have
gotten luckier I he let me run with
everything I had for and it was
beautiful it makes me very happy that a
person and a company like that exists
please feel far between oh yeah super
few in part between and I hope that his
door is absolutely banging down with
people who want to make movies with them
because he's a dream so what is your
first impression when a script like this
crosses your path because it's one of
those movies that has no
easy answers and definitely not one way
to explain at all sure what was your
first impression of what were the
biggest questions you had funny story I
said no at first I said no I had
received I'd received an earlier draft
of the script which was still really
strong and I really liked I loved it the
script is not why I said no is because
at our meeting David assumed that I'd
read the latest draft and I had all
these questions about why certain things
weren't explained or like what these
things meant and he was kind of sitting
there in the meeting on yeah I think
it's in there it's a little bit out he
says how he sounded then so so we we had
like a little misunderstanding and that
was my first impression of the script
but then but then it was figured out
that I got the wrong draft and so I I
read the new one and immediately said
yes because it was just one of those
things I mean I mean I like to work
entirely off intuition and it was one of
those things that I found very easy to
access really immediately because of how
well Charlotte was written and it was
very clear that she was a character that
had been kind of close to David for a
long time and he had kind of I mean he
he knows Charlotte better than I do and
I played her you know - true so it might
be equal now but but that was the kind
of thing where it was like it didn't it
didn't feel like it didn't feel like it
needed anything it didn't feel like I
needed to try really hard to make it
come alive like she already was alive
and it would it just kind of in a you
know this is gonna sound a little
abstract and weird but it it it really
was just kind of slipping slipping into
a ghost that was kind of already there
and already meant something to so many
people and yeah and and it was it was
very easy it was very easy to do what is
it like from your perspective when your
choice to play the lead in your film
says no do you go into into panic mode
and start to come up with other options
or do you figure out the situation like
after our meeting I sent an email
forecaster debate god s is really cool
and then like a day later they like so
she's not down and I was like she is not
cool at all I proved myself again yeah
no I mean it was I mean yes she she just
has an energy is quite like she felt so
complete as a person but in terms of how
she was talking about this script it was
just like it was so insightful and she
was grilling me so I really wanted to
work with her and I'm really glad you
like the new draft and I'm really thanks
me too early conversations and maybe
just working with your entire ensemble
this piece that you spent so much time
on is there anything that any of your
cast kind of brought out of it that you
didn't even know was there after all
that time
yeah for sure I mean I think that like I
think that the the group of friends you
know being Nick and Sam Jack and Maddie
like the the things that we shot with
that like I'm never in scenes with them
really like if charlatan is seen with
them she's like on her thing like she's
she's somewhere else but but their stuff
together the way that they improvised
was incredible and they're all they're
all like well most of them Jack's not
from the south but the other three kids
are and and there was such authenticity
in the way that like southern kids
related to each other that that was
something that was a surprise to me that
I
yeah I'd never read into it that that
thoroughly and that kind of dynamic
between the friends but it yeah it
really kind of popped yeah they just
brought a ton like this what we've been
talking about today is just like when I
was in the editing room just finding
things that she had done on set that I
didn't fully appreciate the weight of
these choices that she made to the point
where they were like they you know they
were unlocking entire Reata to the film
and and it was really exciting but Mady
especially is like South Carolina girl
like you could take the kid out the hood
kind of a situation we can't you know I
mean and she
she's just yeah I mean she is just like
she is that character and so that things
like that I was just so thankful for
because she and she also like played a
really big part in this was something
that I was concerned with because the
movement the movie is obviously so
totally specific that I thought that um
Charlotte this is also something that
we've fought about a lot I thought that
Charlotte like wouldn't seem human
and that that was that kind of fear was
really as waged when Maddie got to set
and when it was like Oh Charlotte like
Charlotte can just be a like a regular
girl hanging out with her friend because
Maddie is so personable and warm and
charming and normal and just like
immediately makes everyone feel
comfortable it's like that that to me
was a really valuable relationship in
the movie and she played it so well
because it would yeah I think it
grounded that that part of Charlotte's
life oh absolutely
another thing that I could feel from
just like the tone and the atmosphere of
the movie is the humidity oh yeah I
assume that was authentic humidity and
not like a makeup artist spritzing here
there was actually like one of the most
popular expressions that David would
like to yell all the time I don't think
I yellow you yellow because that's what
you do he was yeah you just kind of see
like him look checking the monitor and
going like more sweat and so a Jamie
Fraser and and Ashley Thomas who are
incredible makeup artists that we're
working with us we're like running in
with their glycerin bottles and like
trying to make us all look this way is
also like super really the most of its
real like we're shooting in this house
with no electricity you know in the
middle of July and it's like 95 degrees
and there we're on the top floor and
just buckets yep but you know just yeah
it's nice because you can't be cute so
you have to focus really yeah there's
like no trying to look put together in
that environment you just kind of have
to lose your mind I feel like if I
existed there like my bangs would not
allow
to BCE I didn't have I had like stick
straight hair before I made this movie
and the hair that I have in the movie
that's that I haven't done anything to
that my hair just like went into a puff
Bowl and had curls in it all of a sudden
like that had never happened to me in my
entire life and it's like not gone we
were we were all changed just you know
life after work in that area are you
guys all is it an on-location situation
where after the day is done you guys are
kind of hanging out wherever you're
shooting oh yeah so we were Gail them
with tales of the Red Roof okay so the
Red Roof Inn is a motel that no longer
exists in Madison Georgia I think
because of us they had to shut down
really really shortly after we left yeah
we've done everyone was staying in the
same hotel and we're shooting overnights
every night coming back delirious they
get 7:00 in the sun's rising we're
coming back from a full day and then
someone brings out the tequila and then
quite frequently someone brings out the
fireworks and yeah we got to know the
police officers pretty well in that town
for a variety of reasons but it was the
publicists are fine they're not they're
not don't worry we can tell yeah we can
tell these stories right we're not in
any legal trouble it works yeah every
night was like we just sit there and
talk for hours until I got too bright to
see and then sleep for a few hours and
go back to work but I mean it was yeah
it was beautiful yeah David shot me in
the face with a firework that see that's
something we donated it was an accident
no wasn't oh my god no it wasn't oh my
god I was right at the start he was
doing I supposed to do I'm kidding I
want to play one of our games with you
guys really quickly but first I do want
to ask about shooting 35 millimeter on
this what is I guess there's probably an
abundance of red flags or concerns that
when you jump into something like that
but what would you say is the biggest
one for anybody out there who wants to
make their feature using that format
what would you advise them to consider
just do it
just do it the fit I mean I I've only
ever made films on 35 like both my
shorts are shown 35 you make a lot of
sacrifices you will have to it makes
everything a little bit more Spartan but
I think when you are rolling that camera
and you know that money's going through
the gate you're like damn it like I
better mean what I'm saying you know
because it's you have to make sacrifices
and I didn't get paid for all well I
mean I got broke making the movie
probably have my own fault but a lot of
that is because you you get rid of all
the comforts when you shoot on film at
this sort of budget level but I wouldn't
change it trade it for the world because
it was a it's exhilarating because you
shoot something and then you don't know
what happens and then it comes back as
an organic thing like there's like a
it's like a physical reaction and it's
magical and it's all chemical and I'm
obsessed with it so do it nothing bad to
say I'd be like I need to clip that out
and just keep it on my phone for
motivation I don't believe all right so
we're gonna play a little Collider most
memorable moments I have seven topics
here just the first thing that comes to
your minds most memorable movie premiere
that like we've either that you've
attended or for a movie that you made
this one I think you yeah my secret i
hopes count that's um i would have to
say the the kind of sydney premiere of
my first Australian films were memorable
just because it was like you know I was
a kid and I just started acting and like
these these films and two of them happen
at the same time that's actually the
first time I came to TIFF um they were
premiering here at the same time and
every yeah every premiere of those were
just like oh cool this is like happening
this is a very cool thing for a
sixteen-year-old kid to get to
experience this is my first premiere for
one of my own works so this is sick
otherwise Rach worked on the Great
Gatsby and she invited me to the
premiere that and that was really fun
cuz me and all my dumb friends got to
dress up Thank You rage is so special
what is your most memorable meal okay
you know honestly I do love ice cream
but I've got I'm a savory girl through
and through there was a bowl of pasta
that I ate in New Orleans that when I
was shooting there I would cross town
every day that I could to go get this
bowl of pasta and last time I went there
they didn't have it they've gotten rid
of it on the menu because they're idiots
it's the most crushing thing yeah my mom
every year makes a spicy summer soup
she's half Korean said she just we ate
chilies and everything and one
particularly year she made it I had to
leave town the next day but I was flying
out of New York had to drive to New York
and I was carting all this soup would
make someone eat the leftovers my car
broke down the Jersey Turnpike and I had
to travel 200 miles with like cars and
trains to get the suit back to my house
but and then and then I got to enjoy it
eventually and it was it was really it's
really it's really goddamn good I got
the wrap sign so I'm gonna choose one
more and go with oh it's so hard what's
the most memorable scene you've ever
shot whether it's this movie or any
other movie I feel like it just gave you
the hardy somebody says 7676 in this
movie was the most memorable we had the
whole day to shoot it and it was
upstairs in this old house with no
electricity so it was very very very hot
and it's the scene in the movie it's
like essentially like the climax of the
movie and there were tears there were
there was yelling there was storming off
all mine I did all of these things and
that was a very memorable day yeah proud
of a movie to be proud of I hate to say
goodbye have some more questions for you
tonight I have a very hard time saying
no to no but for real though I should
for real
I want the information all right we're
gonna go take care of that I'm gonna say
goodbye to all of you but first a huge
thank you to our sponsors over at
Nordstrom Canada
so much for letting us talk about great
movies like the giant do not leave this
interview without liking and sharing it
make sure you tune in soon because we're
gonna have so much more at TIFF 2019
coverage coming your way soon